in this capsule we will see some
definitions related to the Béziers network in
dynamic
so we saw that a network of a
dynamic it's actually a network
beziers where the notion of time has been
embedded so we want to model a
process that takes place in time
and we go into random variables that
go and clues and by the time or
correspondence and different variables
random we see the variables
excited random which are the
variables associated with it is not
observed in my environment and we will
random variables india and who
are the variables that they are
observed at different times of the
phenomenon that I'm trying to model with
my network beziers so here and the
notion energizes that comes from the fact so we
is modeling a process where
a distribution on elephants
read the forgive elements of our
environment that will vary as and when
as time goes by
so that's all that has specific
from a general point of view on
Dynamic Bezier Networks Resorbed
and normal on the probabilities stage
between the random variables that are
in this case if our set of
variables excited and so was you here
to learn equal tea values ​​1
up to grant and where one could even
model a process that has not
necessarily hungry with big tiger
infinite so we would have been without a
fox and x2 2 a website and in our
bezze network whose coordinator associated with
each of these random variables there
and we have to determine how does that
we connect with arrows so
comment on what you place and a draw other
in a graffit is out of water so
define who the parents are and what
are the tables to enjoy between
different variables which is so there
a somewhat random illustration a
sign and so that's what we have to do
to get the dynamic hobbesien going
to model but variable x is a
index and by the time one of the problems
we are facing is that in
does it may require if we do not
not pay attention
to define a very large number of
probability tables actually we have
need a table of probabilities for
each of the tents and we had a table
quality for each of the excited and
interests and priorities in a network
normal beziers all these steps of
enjoy this very different so that
would do a very large number of tables of
probity has stored in memory and in addition
each table have made a priori for
involve a very large number of
parents so if I am so I
I am interested in the description 2 x 1 then
2nd st leu in this case too I have all
the former one up to 99 and 1 to 99
that I can use it as parents
potential to his two voids
so that will be another problem we are going
to think about commenting on what we
defines our parents for refusing
beziers that still usable in
convenient
then we will see three solutions to these
problems there three assumptions we're going
do that will allow us to get
hobbesian dynamic networks need
dynamics that are usable in
practical and that are still useful
solves various problems
so the first solution
it may be to assume that the
dynamic changes associated with my
environment
so the changes in the distribution
variables from my environment to
as time goes by
will match what's called a
stationing process what it wants
to actually say it's just that the
probabilities of but random variable
excited upstream associates and to hide and
also the probabilities the
distributions two associated with
variables that are not going to change in
time for example as far as
the distribution of tillage equipment
existed at time t given its
parents it's going to be the same for all
size values ​​so what that
does that mean that pdx including x12
know the image of its parent cx1 and that
imagine that for x3 we only have that
depends only 2 x 2 ben it's two
distributions were exactly the
same is going to be the same tables of
conditional policy stored in
memory for these two distributions
envelope and it's going to be really done
whatever the time index here
it's true for aix 4 knowing x3 or x5
knowing that they are capturing and institutes and
so in this case also we do not know the
main property behind what we
call a stationary process that's
to say that it's always the same
distribution that models the
changes of my state x of a state you
in the next step and plus 1 the
second solution
its high size to assume that the
dynamic changes that are all at
and stamps continues a
process we're going to say marco well what
that means a marco process
so it's actually the toques
will depend only on a man ends
of previous state and the case that we will see
the mainly in the capsules that
is going to be that of a process mark
comic we will say first-rate
that is, the distribution of
excited knowing all the variables
random associated with x time 1
to the tempted - a gift that's what
1.2 point witness at the hearing and which one
can see on the vector x variables
2 x 1 until excited - 1
so this distribution here is going in
actually be modeled where we do there
suppose dependencies
conditional which makes that this
distribution is equal to p2 excited sacha
only existed minus 1 so in
other words if I know the hidden state
at the position or at the moment t - 1
I do not need to know the others
variables know excited -2 ​​up to x1
so I do not need to know them
to find out how was generated xt from
more technical way it means that
Says ex witnesses are excited and
independent of six witnesses two up
aix and so that's a marco process
comes from first rank have said that this
first dress because we are going to search
a random variable
in front the last random variable
second order
we would only depend on x
witnesses hours and excite - clashes -
two would have been so we would have cost
less of here it would be second order
and institutes so this model here here on
commented what my and the seal
changes from one state to another so what
call the transition model
so the transition model this is
which models the transitions between mountains
and to hide and from one moment to another and
so this is the second position that makes
that in fact in this case but tape of
probabilities will not depend on a
increasing number of elements they go into
talk about one piece of knowledge
in the code of a chain of a process
marc collienne first rank he goes
depend on a single element before so
to have a single parent if it takes big
policy steps will not be too much
serious and six in the third 6
positions that we will often do is
the one that observation and generate
the observation generated solely by the
current rates so that means that the
distribution of what is observed at
time t given all hidden states
previous state of time 1 until
attempted and all the observations of the
time 1 until the previous time and -1
will actually be reduced by the
tea distribution sacha the kosher state
or even time ie xt so that's
technically means that shan the vise
stamp at a given moment
the distribution of observations to this
moment is independent of forgiveness the
random variable of observations to
the moment t will be dependent on all
states hide extras until xt
-1 and will also be dependent on
observations or in 1 until witnesses
ok so knowing excite a tea is
independent of all these variables at the
canvas
so this distribution here here we go
call it the observation model
since it's a model defined a
distribution on my observations
knowing in that it's only my
and takashi and by doing are still a
once we have managed to have a network
dynamic pleasure have a table step
of distribution that will not be too
great in this case also the head of
distribution sells a size that is going to be
proportional to the number of values
possible for observations both on
number of initials possible for the state
hide what is very reasonable in
practice compared to a table of
distribution that would have depended that who
would be addicted to everything they
had before having an example of
the application of these three positions there
imagine that we want to model the
following situation we kept a
security that spends a month in a
underground building get by and every
day his director arrives with or without
people
so that's the observation that our
security guard does to all
days and the keeper wants a ferrer it's
what is the possibility that is more
or not depending on the sequence of
observations of the umbrella that bring or
not the
the director in this case varied dishes
upstream and with the csq stamp and rain or
not it's a reign
and so that's it I'll use rt
as of attention for this barrier was
war there and then but variable observed that
is going maybe the director has
led his father rained in English a three of a kind
or not so we will use ut as
symbol since behind the canvas and
so if we want to implement network
bezian that satisfies all
assumptions that I mentioned
previously the three assumptions but
it gives us a network although the
next structure so we notice
the excited state so exist that corresponds
in my favor at war rtd during his
godfather is only aix
witness so no arrow directly
between exist and else and takashi
before or observations recalled
also the distribution or by the null
to rely on hunting observations so
a blaze the author goes
but only as parent the variable
random excited because if that's it
means that if I know rtm relay
were the parents of all the others
all other variables
previous random because rt so I
crt it's going to block the path between here
and all other variables
previous random
and finally the lottery position this is
that actually the table to enjoy rt
sacha rt - hours it's the same table
pole tes that the table to enjoy rt
more sincere herti this is exactly the
same table for all the values ​​of
possible tea then in the same way the
table to enjoy 1 volt and sasha rt
it was exactly the same as the one
narrated plus a sacha llorenti plus a
well same thing for a sample three of a kind
a sacha gathered witnesses
my observation model is the same
for all the moments your data
so that's the kind of structures we
will take our network beziers it's a
otherwise bezian network that like the
Roubaisiens we had before the state
enjoy
we have a serious no variables
random the probabilities step
define the distribution of these
random variables there what we have
added it's constraints on which
kind of connection have little to see what
kind of arrow we can have between nonu
is also add the fact that
the probabilities stage are linked in
in the different moments that I
model with my Béziers network